[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen im Sport
unter anderem der Blick auf den
DFB-Pokal mit Norbert Lehmann einen
schönen guten Abend unsere
der Minister bei der Truppe Boris
bistorius besucht das Bataillon das 14
Leopard Panzer an die Ukraine abgibt
Hightech aus dem Saarland auf dem
Gelände eines stillgelegten Kraftwerks
soll eine riesige Fabrik für Mikrochips
entstehen
und Masken aus im Bus und Bahn ab morgen
entfällt bundesweit die Tragepflicht im
nah und Fernverkehr in medizinischen
Einrichtungen bleibt sie bestehen
[Musik]
für die Leopard Panzer die an die
Ukraine gehen soll die Bundeswehr
schneller Satz bekommen er werde sich
mit Nachdruck dahinter klemmen sagte
jetzt Bundesverteidigungsminister bist
dorius aber die Nachbeschaffung brauche
seine Zeit
Pistorius besuchte heute das
Panzerbataillon das Leoparden in die
Ukraine abgibt ein Bericht von torgebode
das sind zwei der 14 Kampfpanzer vom Typ
Leopard 2 A6 die in den nächsten Wochen
an die Ukraine geliefert werden sollen
und der Verteidigungsminister ist heute
an Bord Besuch beim Panzerbataillon 203
in Augustdorf Pistorius wirbt für
Verständnis bei den Soldatinnen und
Soldaten den in die Panzer erst einmal
fehlen werden
also jetzt quasi
Enzo das ist seine Herbert eine herbe
Angelegenheit für sie nicht mehr
schmerzlich bewusst eigentlich stehen
dem Bataillon 32 Leopard Panzer zur
Verfügung nach der Auslieferung an die
Ukraine bleiben allerdings nur fünf
einsatzbereite Kampffahrzeuge übrig denn
acht stehen in Liter und fünf sind
kaputt damit ist das Bataillon nur
bedingt einsatzbereit
das Problem natürlich vor dem
Hintergrund des knappen Materials den
gedachten aufwuchs der Bundeswehr die
Bundeswehr sollte eigentlich größer
werden er stellt sich natürlich auch wie
schnell und wie lange muss ich darauf
warten um dieses Gerät nach zu
beschaffen der Minister strebt eine
schnelle Wiederbeschaffung an die
Gespräche mit der Industrie laufen doch
es wird wohl dauern
gegenwärtig ist es so dass man drei
Jahre auf einer neuen Panzer erwartet
und nach drei Jahren kommen eben zwei
Panzer pro Monat das heißt man würde
dreieinhalb Jahre warten diese
Bestellung wieder auffüllen ausgebildet
am Leopard 2 Panzer werden die
ukrainischen Soldatinnen und Soldaten in
den nächsten Wochen im niedersächsischen
Munster das teilte der Minister heute
mit
Unterstützung durch weitere Waffen das
ist das eine das die Ukraine vom Westen
erwartet das andere ist eine stärkere
politische Bindung etwa durch eine
Mitgliedschaft in der EU deren Spitzen
kommen nun nach Kiew angeführt von
Kommissionspräsidenten von der Leyen
Präsident selenski erwartet nach eigenen
Worten vom eu-ukraine-gipfel übermorgen
Entscheidungen und verspricht dafür
werde das Land andere Formen arbeiten in
Kiew traf heute
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin Gören Eckert
ein sie war für eine EU-Beitritt der
Ukraine allerdings nur wenn alle
notwendigen Kriterien erfüllt sein
und ein Kiew ist für uns Katrin
Eigendorf und in Brüssel Ulf röhla gehen
wir als erstes in Ukraine zu ihnen
Kathrin selensky erwartet also
Entscheidungen was stellt er sich
konkret vor
ja also der ukrainische Präsident möchte
natürlich mehr als nur die Symbolik
wenngleich auch die Symbole unglaublich
wichtig ist für das Land in diesem
Moment wo es ja wirklich an einem
Tiefpunkt angelangt ist was sowohl die
Kämpfer angeht als auch die soziale
Situation aber die Perspektive möglichst
schnell die Ukraine in Europa zu sehen
integriert in die Europäische Union das
ist eines der großen politischen und
wichtigsten Ziele für silensky und
deswegen will er eben mehr als nur
Gesten sondern im Prinzip klarer
Abkommen treffen aber ich denke mal die
ukrainische Regierung ist auch
realistisch genug dass sie weiß dass es
dazu so schnell nicht kommen wird klar
Abkommen ist der Wunsch und voller
Brüssel ja was ist denn realistisch was
wird die EU im Gepäck haben für die
Ukraine
also hier in Brüssel hat man vor der
Abreise immer wieder bedroht dass dieser
Besuch absolut historisch ist das dürfte
man nicht unterschätzen es ist nämlich
das erste Mal dass die Kommission in ein
Kriegsgebiet fährt und damit eben
wirklich auch Risiken auf sich nimmt und
sie will deutlich machen wie eng sie an
der Ukraine dran ist man wird auch
konkret etwas mitbringen man wird die
Trainingsmission der ukrainischen
Soldaten von 15.000 auf 30.000 ausweiten
aber es wird wahrscheinlich auf der
ukraischen Seite auch Enttäuschungen
geben nämlich die Waffen die sich die
Ukraine wünscht die wird Europa nicht so
schnell und vielleicht gar nicht liefern
und bei dem großen Thema EU-Beitritt der
Ukraine wird man auch auf die Bremse
treten und der Ukraine sagen so schnell
geht es nicht die Kriterien müssen
erfüllt sein und da ist immer noch das
große Thema Korruption was über die
Ukraine schwebt insofern wird das große
wichtige Bilder geben aber es wird auch
klar sein Realität wird nicht
überschattet von den schönen Bildern
danke für diese Einschätzung darf
ja und Katrin Eigendorf unter
Militärhistoriker Sönke neitze sind
nachher zu Gast bei heute live ab 1940
geht es um den vermögungskrieg um
bachmut zu sehen in der ZDF heute App
und auf unseren Social Media Kanälen
infolge des ukraine-krieges steigen die
Energiepreise zwar weiter aber nicht
mehr so stark wie zuletzt und dadurch
hat sich die Inflation in der Eurozone
weiter abgeschwächt die
Verbraucherpreise legten im Januar
gegenüber dem Vorjahresmonat um 8,5% zu
wie das europäische Statistikamt Eurosat
mitteilte im Dezember hatte die
Inflation noch bei 9,2% gelegen und so
wie Europa leiden aber auch die USA
weiter unter hohen Verbraucherpreisen
US-Präsident beiden setzt daher auf ein
370 Milliarden Dollar schweres
Förderprogramm klimafreundlicher
Technologie einem Gesetz zur Reduzierung
der Inflation die EU ist alles andere
als begeistert fürchteten Nachteile für
europäische Unternehmen
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
hat daher heute eigene Subventionen
vorgeschlagen mehr von Isabell Schäfers
die EU soll mithalten können soll als
Industriestandort nicht abgehängt werden
deshalb kündigt die
eu-kommissionspräsidentin heute an mehr
Staatshilfen allerdings gezielt nur für
grüne Industriebranchen important ist
wichtig ist dass die Subventionen die ja
nationale Finanzhilfen sind die von den
Mitgliedstaaten investiert werden dass
diese zielgerichtet und zeitlich
begrenzt eingesetzt werden genau das tut
die US-Regierung bereits mit ihrem
Inflation reduction Act grüne
Technologie wie zum Beispiel die
Produktion von E-Autos wird staatlich
gefördert und so der Industriestandort
USA gestärkt die Sorge in Europa immer
mehr Produktionsstätten könnten dorthin
abwandern in der EU müssen staatliche
Beihilfen von Brüssel genehmigt werden
das Verfahren soll jetzt schneller und
einfacher werden man muss darauf gucken
völlig okay aber es darf nicht mehr zwei
Jahre oder drei Jahre dauern das muss
innerhalb vom halben Jahr durchgeführt
werden längstens ein Problem dass sich
anbahnt große finanzstarke Länder können
mehr Subventionen an die heimische
Wirtschaft geben als andere das
angedachte Gegenmittel ein neuer
eu-fördertopf we must wir müssen jede
Art von Spaltung des europäischen
Binnenmarktes vermeiden wenn man
nationale staatliche Beihilfen will muss
es auch Finanzierung auf EU-Ebene geben
Deutschland und andere Länder sind
dagegen und so gibt es noch keine
einheitliche europäische Antwort an die
USA kommende Woche wird sich der
EU-Gipfel mit den Vorschlägen befassen
und die EU will noch mehr es geht um die
wichtigen aber derzeit so knappen
Halbleiter bisher werden zu wenige in
Europa hergestellt das soll sich jetzt
ändern heute gab es da einen wichtigen
Schritt auch aus deutscher Sicht der
us-konzernhofspeed Wilhelm Saarland eine
chip-fabrik bauen damit beteiligt auch
der deutsche Autozulieferer ZDF die
Details hat Susanne Freitag
der Bundeskanzler da in den Händen hält
soll die Zukunft der
energietransformation sein den
silikonkabine Chip hat der Chef der
amerikanischen Firma wolfspeed
mitgebracht zum ehemaligen
Kohlekraftwerk Ensdorf hier will Wulf
Speed gemeinsam mit dem Getriebe
Hersteller ZF die größte Fabrik für
silikon-chips der Welt bauen mitten im
Saarland
sehr qualifizierte Arbeitskräfte die
Lage ist zentral in der Nähe von
Frankreich Luxemburg Belgien die
Automobilindustrie rundherum ist sehr
stark es gab einen enormen globalen
Wettbewerb aber die Kombination all
dieser Dinge hat uns im Saarland am
meisten überzeugt
früher Kohle heute Zukunft nicht nur
eine chip-fabrik sondern auch ein
Forschungszentrum sollen entstehen mit
Silikon Beach Chips sollen E-Autos an
Reichweite gewinnen und schneller laden
können Produktion am Standort
Deutschland ein Schritt in Richtung
Energie
gerade die Erfahrung der Pandemie haben
uns gelehrt dass wir in Deutschland und
Europa in technologischer digitaler und
logistischer Hinsicht resilienter werden
müssen
deshalb werden wir Abhängigkeiten und
Verwundbarkeiten systematisch verringern
es ist ein Milliardenprojekt auch Bund
und Land tragen einen Teil der Kosten
sie haben Fördergelder bei der EU
beantragt ohne die solche Projekte nicht
finanzierbar wären um solche Dilemma zu
verhindern dass wir also sozusagen
stehen bleiben technologisch ist auch
wichtig hier Fördergelder durch
Fördergelder eine gewisse Stabilität zu
erreichen wenn es grünes Licht aus
Brüssel gibt sondern auch in diesem Jahr
mit den Bauarbeiten begonnen werden
immer noch Bang rund 17.000 Beschäftigte
des angeschlagenen warenhaus-konzerns
Galeria um ihre Zukunft heute hat das
Insolvenzverfahren in Eigenregie
begonnen geplant ist eine bessere
Verzahnung von stationärem und
Online-Handel die verbleibenden Filialen
sollen sich außerdem mehr an den lokalen
Bedürfnissen ausrichten welche Standorte
geschlossen werden ist aber noch unklar
der Kohleausstieg könnte auch in
Ostdeutschland vorgezogen werden ohne
die Stromversorgung zu gefährden zu
diesem Ergebnis kommt ein Bericht der
Bundesnetzagentur das lange ist ein
früheres aus nur für die rheinischen
kohlriviere vorgesehen nämlich 2030
statt 38 für den ostdeutschen Tagebau
ist das umstritten laut
Bundesnetzagentur wäre ein vorgezogenes
Ende allerdings nur dann möglich wenn
die erneuerbaren Energien weiter
ausgebaut werden
die Bundesregierung hat den Weg frei
gemacht für das 49 euro-ticket und zwar
mit einem Gesetz dass die Zuschüsse des
Bundes regelt das landesweit gültige
Monatsticket soll am 1 Mai starten und
dann im regional und Nahverkehr gelten
ziel ist es dass Bahn und Bus fahren
günstiger und die Tarifstrukturen
einfacher zu machen
Bundestag Bundesrat und auch die
EU-Kommission müssen aber noch zustimmen
fast drei Jahre lang galt in Deutschland
Bus und Bahn fahren nur mit Maske nun
steht diese corona-maßnahme vor dem Aus
im öffentlichen Nahverkehr hatten fünf
Bundesländer die maskenpflicht bereits
abgeschafft heute folgen Hamburg und
Nordrhein-Westfalen morgen fällt die
Pflicht im ÖPNV alle anderen Länder weg
und auch im Fernverkehr braucht es dann
bundesweit keine Maske mehr was ich
sonst noch ändert und was gleich bleibt
erklärt sie Wille Wasser
maskenpflicht den Fernzügen damit ist ab
heute Nacht Schluss an die neue Freiheit
müssen sich manche allerdings erst noch
gewöhnen naja ob das mal gut ist ich
weiß es nicht ich finde es falsch aber
ich respektiere natürlich alles und ich
kann sie ja auch zum Schutz für mich
tragen ich finde es gut weil ich glaube
die Leute müssen langsam wieder lernen
ein bisschen selbstverantwortlich sein
Selbstverantwortung steht Vorschriften
in Bayern endete die maskenpflicht im
Nahverkehr schon vor sieben Wochen die
Skepsis im Hinblick auf eine Zunahme der
Infektionszahlen war zunächst groß ist
eine positive Bilanz wir haben uns das
ja sehr gut überlegt wir haben abgewogen
die infektionslage ist stabil ihr
zurückgehen und deshalb gehen Bayern und
andere Länder weitere Schritte weg mit
der Maske heißt es bei
Gemeinschaftsunterkünften
Rettungsdiensten oder Arztpraxen
allerdings nur für die Beschäftigten
viel zu früh so der Internist Tobias
golowski Moment müssen wir nicht genau
wie es weitergeht also vielleicht
verstanden dass man maskenpflicht in
Arztpraxen beibehält in Kliniken
Senioren und Pflegeheimen gilt die
maskenpflicht laut
Infektionsschutzgesetz nach wie vor für
Apotheker Peter Auernhammer eine
sinnvolle Entscheidung vulnerable
Gruppen müssten weitergeschützt werden
wenn den Kliniken wo frische operierte
Leute sind auch da macht sicher Sinn und
kann man jedem zumuten zum Schutz der
anderen Maske zu tragen Maske hin oder
her die Aufhebung der Pflicht im nah und
Fernverkehr ist sicherlich ein weiterer
Schritt in Richtung Normalität
Verhaftungen Repressionen 1,5 Millionen
Binnenflüchtlinge das ist Miramar zwei
Jahre nachdem sich das Militär an die
Macht putschte 1 Februar 2021 die
demokratisch gewählte Regierung von
Friedensnobelpreisträgerin ensan soucci
wird gestürzt so Ziel selbst wird
festgenommen und weggesperrt heute am
Jahrestag des Putsches hat das Militär
den Ausnahmezustand um sechs Monate
verlängert Namen odental
aus der Luft mit aller Härte Myanmars
Militär fliegt immer wieder solche
Angriffe macht Jagd auf Opposition am
Boden ein Kampf mit ungleichen Mitteln
hat ein Bein verloren aber sein
Widerstand bleibt entschlossen
ich bereue nichts den Kampf meine
Verletzung ich habe diesen Weg gewählt
denn dieser Weg ist richtig wenn es mir
wieder besser geht kämpfe ich weiter
gegen die runter weiter bis zum Ende
zwei Jahre seit dem Putsch die runter
feiert sich als Bewahrer der Stabilität
und herrscht mit brutaler Gewalt der
tausende schon zum Opfer fielen dennoch
bleiben dem Regime Freunde allen voran
China und Russland liefern Geld und
Waffen für dieses Jahr sind Wahlen
versprochen aber falls es die gibt was
sind sie wert
Wahlen sind nicht frei und fair wenn es
Verhaftungen Folter Exekutionen von
Oppositionellen gibt und auch nicht wenn
Journalisten verboten wird ihren Job zu
machen
die letzten freien Wahlen hatte sie
gewonnen augensanzuji das war drei
Monate vor dem Putsch das letzte was man
jetzt von ihr sah war ein Bild in den
staatlichen Nachrichten die Wahlsiegerin
im Gerichtssaal verurteilt zu 33 Jahren
Haft das Militär räumt seine Gegner aus
dem Weg so oder so
drei deutsche Städte haben heute eine
Auszeichnung gefeiert die sie eigentlich
schon vor eineinhalb Jahren bekommen
haben
da hatte die UNESCO das jüdische Kultur
geht gut von Speyer Worms und Mainz als
welterbanerkannt nach den
Anfangsbuchstaben ihrer hebräischen
Schreibweise hatten sich die Gemeinden
im Mittelalter und den Namen Schuhen
zusammengeschlossen die schummstädte
gelten als Wiege des mitteleuropäischen
Judentums die feierliche Übergabe der
Urkunde mit Bundespräsident steinmark
einmal gab es pandemiebedingt erst heute
Christel Hass berichtet
ehrfürchtig steht der Besucher aus
Florida vor den uralten Grabsteinen des
jüdischen Friedhofs von Worms
die jüdische Tradition sie ist hier
entstanden durch all die Rabbiner die
hier lebten und die hier auf diesem
Friedhof begraben sind
und noch ein anderer Gast besuchte
diesen Ort der jetzt zum Welt Erbe zählt
Bundespräsident Steinmeier warum es war
mit Speyer und Mainz eins das jüdische
Zentrum von Europa
Baudenkmäler Synagogen Gemeinderäume sie
erinnern uns an Zeiten in denen
Christen Juden und Andersgläubige gerade
hier in der Region
nicht nebeneinander sondern miteinander
lebten
das Ritualbad in Speyer im Mittelalter
prägten die schulstätte die Kultur und
das Leben und es wurden erstaunlich
moderne Regeln erlassen die ein Ehe etwa
oder das Briefgeheimnis
jüdisches Leben in Deutschland heißt
aber auch Pogrome Vertreibung Mord
1938 brannten viele Synagogen auch die
von Worms
Judenfeindlichkeit dürfe keinen Platz
haben in Deutschland sagte Steinmeier
bei einer Feierstunde in Mainz die
unesco-generaldirektorin meinte der Welt
erbe-titel sei auch Verpflichtung
wir dürfen die dunkle Zeit der Schuhe
nicht vergessen wir müssen aber auch an
das Leben denken das ist davor gab
[Musik]
nun ist der Titel offiziell er ist
Auszeichnung und Mahnung zugleich
jetzt kommen wir zum Sport zum DFB-Pokal
Norbert gestern Abend die ersten beiden
Achtelfinals mit knappen Siegen der
Favoriten fangen wir an mit Union gegen
Wolfsburg die Berliner Tabellenzweite in
der Liga die taten sich anfangs schwer
mit schlechten Wetter und guten Gegner
dann eine turbulente Schlussphase in der
Union die Nase vorn hatte
[Applaus]
war glücklich denn dieses Pokalspiel war
nichts für schwache Nerven Mannschaft
hat sich diesen Sieg wirklich
erarbeitet tolle Moral gezeigt denn den
Staat haben die Berliner komplett
verschlafen Wolfsburg mit der frühen
Führung Luca Waldschmidt und das 1:0 für
den Minute 5 doch Union gelang es diesen
Rückstand zu drehen yuranovic mit der
Flanke und ausgerechnet der frühere
Wolfsburger Robin Knoche stand
goldrichtig 12 minute der Ausgleich doch
es brauchte bis zum Schluss Phase für
die Entscheidung in der 79 Minute Köfte
Geraldo Becker auf Kevin Behrens und der
traf zum 2:1 Sieg Union im Viertelfinale
und die zweite Begegnung gestern Abend
Paderborn gegen Stuttgart der VfB
gewinnt 2:1 ein Zählspiel mit einem
kuriosen Eigentor ein spätes Glück der
Stuttgarter und eine eigenwillige
Zählweise des Trainers am drei Tore
gemacht heute am Platz das also das
zeigt auch dass wir da torgefährlich
sind Labbadia hat nicht unrecht beim
sehenswerten Eigentor von marokkolos aus
48 m Entfernung hat kein Paderborner
auch nur minimalen Anteil den
Verteidiger und Torwart Müller kann ein
blindes Verständnis sicher nicht
bescheinigt werden doch dann sticht der
blitztransfer der Portugiese diasch von
Benfica Lissabon gerade erst ausgeliehen
mit dem Ausgleich 5 Minuten vor Schluss
und in der fünften nachspielminute
girasi mit dem dritten Treffer eines
Stuttgarters zum 2:1 klingt paradox war
aber so
ja allerdings und alle Höhepunkte der
dfb-achtelfinals auch der beiden heute
Abend zu sehen war heute die und in der
heute App
Superstar Tom Brady beendet seine
Karriere als footballprofi
guten Morgen Leute ich will direkt auf
den Punkt kommen ich höre auf für immer
klare Worte des 45-Jährigen Quarterbacks
mit seinen Tampa Bay Backen jetzt war er
zuvor in den NFL Playoffs ausgeschieden
Brady ist der erfolgreichste
Footballspieler der Geschichte ja vor
einem Jahr hat er schon mal seinen
Rücktritt erklärt aber ich glaube das
ist echt ernst schade eigentlich
Geschichte zu Ende und wir kommen jetzt
zu einem Stück Luftfahrtgeschichte was
zu Ende geht die letzte 7 wurde
ausgeliefert der Jumbo auch Königin der
Lüfte genannt hat über 50 Jahre den
Flugverkehr geprägt lange war das größte
Passagierflugzeug der Welt so hat er
längere Reisen für viele schwinglich
gemacht oben drauf gab es diese
spektakulären Bilder die sieben vier
sieben als Taxi für das Space Shuttle
der NASA
und jetzt kommen wir zu den Lottozahlen
die Gewinnzahlen lauten 620 34 36 40 49
Superzahl ist die 5 weiter Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf Lotto Punkt zdf.de und im
ZDF Text auf Seite 557
ungemütlich nass wird's mehr dazu
gleichem Wetter von öst Intelli das
heute journal mit Anne gerlindek können
Sie um 21:45 Uhr
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die Tendenz zu
warmer Januar Monate setzt sich weiter
fort und so war der vergangene Monat
viel zu warm und fällt unter die zehn
wärmsten vier Grad zu warm war und lokal
natürlich noch wärmer zum Beispiel nach
Osten hier um 5 Grad zu warm ja derzeit
kommt ja etwas kühlere Luft dann aus dem
Norden das bedeutet Regen aber auch
Schnee in den höheren Lagen der ist
teilweise sogar ergiebig in der Nacht
z.B nach Südosten hin aber auch in den
östlichen Mittelgebirgen allgemein und
an den Alpen kräftiger Schneefall im
Westen Regen und an den Küsten noch
Sturm der allmählich nachlassen dass bei
tiefsten Temperaturen von -1 Grad im
Vogtland und 7 Grad ganz im Westen
morgen dann weitere Schneefälle in den
östlichen Mittelgebirgen und an den
alten teils ergiebig nach Nordosten hin
ist es deutlich ruhiger mit Sonnenschein
und das bei höchsten Temperaturen von 0
bis teils neun Grad ganz im Westen
Deutschlands die kommenden Tage bleiben
wechselhaft Freitag weiterer Schnee vor
allem an den Alpen bei drei bis zehn
Grad vor allem Sonntag wird ziemlich
durchwachsen ein schöner Abend